en algún lugar cerca de las
constelaciones de escorpio y sagitario
se encuentra un agujero negro
supermasivo a unos 26.000 años de luz de
nuestro planeta para nosotros los
terrícolas parecería del tamaño de una
rosquilla sentada en la luna cada gran
galaxia tiene un agujero en su centro
estos misteriosos fenómenos tienen una
atracción gravitacional tan fuerte que
se comen toda la materia incluida la luz
y son casi imposibles de detectar ahora
una colaboración internacional de
investigadores ha creado la primera
imagen del monstruo invisible de nuestra
galaxia en el mundo el difuso anillo
naranja representa el gas incandescente
y en el centro el gran agujero de una
dimensión cuatro millones de veces mayor
a la de nuestro sol para obtener estas
imágenes ocho gigantes observatorios de
todo el mundo se juntaron para formar el
único telescopio virtual llamado ht del
tamaño de un planeta
y tomar una foto con el ht es como
escuchar una canción tocada por un piano
al que le faltan muchas teclas como no
sabemos cuándo hay que pulsar las teclas
que faltan hay un sinfín de posibles
melodías que podrían estar sonando sin
embargo con suficientes teclas que
funcionan en nuestro cerebro puede
rellenar los huecos para reconocer la
canción correctamente 300 investigadores
de 80 institutos han trabajado en ellos
durante varios años no es la primera vez
que se usa esta tecnología en el 2019 el
ht publicó la primera foto de un agujero
negro la estrella m87 que no está en la
vía láctea sino en otra galaxia a unos
53 millones de años luz los científicos
ya se han dado cuenta de las similitudes
entre ambas fotografías cada imagen
ayuda a los investigadores a saber más
sobre uno de los objetos más misteriosos
de nuestro universo